ils ont une chance de se trouver sur 60
secondes à 60 secondes pour rassembler
des équipements et survivre dans un
bunker
l'un des buts de bonis là ok le chrono
est lancée il faut que je chante des
gens là des petits médoc nous mais bien
ça comment nous bloquer j'ai pris je
sais pas quand j'ai fait un petit effort
petit téléphone pour appeler les secours
ça y est vous tous m'ont rien c'est ce
que je peux prendre femme et enfants oui
à les pistons et ce coût pour notre
femme qui ont fait pas les faisait plus
refait pas les fdp on va la prendre a
pas se mentir alors une hache si c'est
la guerre en bas on pourra se déforme
mais il nous faudra prouve surtout de la
bouffe de la bouffe c'est où la bouffe
d'afrique allait gérer après j'ai pas
pris de rides sur mon cas on a appris
juste une hache
voilà ma survie arbres abattus tâche
jour 1 on va survivre deux jours carnet
de notes
nos ressources sont à ces mecs pour
l'instant personne ne se plaint mais il
se peut que la soupe en bois deviennent
bientôt un plat de luxe c'est une
tristesse font appel à ces temps pour
collecter tout le nécessaire c'est
normal ça c'est juste que mec qui
contrôlent connaissez pas la touche
d'accord nous tuera sur ce que tu as on
n'a qu'une soupe mec mais mon gars et je
viens d'enfants tweet qu'elle perd je
suis butin hockey jouera pas ses
ouailles à la petite barque hibou ce
sont par exemple jours de nourriture pas
de barbe aux questions de audouard
rationaliser les ressources n'avons
peut-être deux jours sans manger ne vous
foutez pas de ma gueule on est des
guerriers stade est assez vigoureux pour
risquer une expédition pour veille de
l'aurès et timmy peut le faire michael
devrait-on lancer l'exposition demain
allez hockey jour 3 regardez moi cette
bonne graisse et leur bonne santé la
même s'ils mangent pas alors on va
encore leur donner que de l'eau de quoi
l'on va rien leur donner comment
s'équiper pour l'expédition open h
aulas pacha qu'est ce qu'on en voit on
voit envoyé jean michel gros avec une
hache si on va laisser le femmes et
enfants au foyer à l'abri ses héroïques
ou pas ok je crois qu'il va nous ramener
10 boîtes de soupe
il est plus là sûr c'est vachement père
sûrement une fois agir sinon on commence
à parler à soi-même au la radio
il revient le jeu richelle grèce ou pas
peut-être le moment est venu pour que tu
m'aies boivent et il n'a pas l'air bien
ok de l'eau pour vous les enfants ont
été presque dans les bras de morphée
qu'on a entendu quelqu'un frapper à la
porte
ouvrir ou pas c'est jean-michel grèce
qui oublié les clés du coeur allait au
nouveau quelques voyages iron mask ha
gazh traînant derrière eux un équipement
apparemment très sophistiqué nous ont
donné un peu d'eau filtrée
d'accord on sait avant l'apocalypse il a
des mecs qui distribue des bouteilles
d'eau la sono les ressources va pas se
mentir
ah non ils ont joué aux architectes
d'intérieur et ils ont trouvé une porte
mystérieuse caché dans le bunker
sauf que pour l'ouvrier fois refusées ou
une lampe torche a jamais anticipé là je
fais pas la lampe en a je suis désolé un
jour 7
il revient quand le mari mais qu ai-je
il est mort je pense à je suis près sûr
qu'il est mort 1
mint est des revenus sains et saufs de
l'expédition j'ai regagné ma h enfin son
expédition il ya des avions qui ont
largué des caisses et la lampe torche et
peut-être dans lesquelles ça j'avais
anticipé en plus de soupe est un génial
et plus de bouteille d'eau aussi ses
géniales tête il a faim soif et la ebola
aller demain timmy va aller seul dans le
désert à jour 9
il a réussi à attraper un signal quoique
faible et à se synchroniser avec les
fréquences des communiqués du
gouvernement général zia dimitri va avec
ta petite hache au revoir mon fils bonne
chance je t'aime son papounet adoré jour
ted a faim ou éloquente et nathan besoin
d'elle à temps mais ce mec qui
consomment plus qu'une vue à 4 4 quoi
tous les jours vous lui filer sa petite
bouteille d'eau et sa soupe quoi page à
diana rencontrons des gens vêtus en
blanc comme des enfants qui se déguise
en médecin alors oui ils demandent si on
n'aurait pas un peu d'oxygène est de
trop bon alors donné l'ordre d'aller un
jour 12 dette n'a pas faim ni soif
merci ted parce que là depuis tout à
l'heure peut-être pas trop apprécié ces
moments de malaise à des jours très ces
parties à l'ets team est amer non il est
mort c'est sûr à l'intimé revient robien
il déborde on était des deux roues tout
oppose deux il a perdu 28 kg si leur
dépression jour 15 contacts établis
l'armée opère toujours et viennent au
secours et on doit patienter aux
tibétains et des ressources ou pas une
soupe et un magazine
on croit qu' après l'explosion d'un
bombe nucléaire personnes nous appellent
ray plus mais on entend très clairement
la sonnerie du téléphone venant de
l'extérieur
c'est un bug informatique vous faites
pas avoir elle ne peut venir que de la
cabine téléphonique de l'autre côté de
la rue faut-il y aller prendre la pelle
dolores est pour toi jour 16 est déjà
revenu quand on a décroché on a entendu
quelqu'un poussé un grand soupir de
soulagement malheureusement tout à coup
de coin stations étaient interrompus
quelque chose à dubois tournée de leur
côté [ __ ] tout bascule même des bois
de chance elle c'est soit notre bonjour
un tremblement des retours sur le masque
à gaz sont sous la radio la radio c'est
l'espoir mec c'est l'espoir à nom du
coup le masque à gaz il est cassé mais
qu allait dolores par d'expédition et
ravel ou de la bouffe on est mort ce
jour 18
la dépression est toujours présente sur
ces visages timide ne nous a pas dit que
quand il est parti en expédition il sait
faire gratiner par un fil de fer ou
quelque chose de rouille et sa blessure
n'a pas l'air bien on doit faire quelque
chose il faut une hache et une trousse
de soin mais make bas on n'a pas tous à
moi tu vas crever un tunnel on t'aimait
dolores revient s'il te plaît est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on a plus qu'une demi
souper une bouteille d'eau oui dans la
merde devant 21
ado la salle fait quoi et car en
particulier sa vie avec un autre
bailleur ou venez terminé de manger
quand un truc est qu'à frapper à la
porte le visiteur s'est introduit comme
un marché en quête de munitions qu'est
ce qu'on fait on le but et le beauf jour
22h28 ah non là c'est de retour comme
dirait le cher au mague d'accord donc le
juste autorisés note sam trammell a
ramené deux sous c'est pas mal ça est un
jeu de cartes
je crois qu'on arrive à la fin jean
xxiii toi tu vas aller dehors avec une
hache mon gros jour 24 l'armée mais
encore la priorité localiser tous les
survivants
annoncé avec lampe torche on aurait pu
faire des signes un avion ya quelqu'un
qui a frappé à la porte et propose une
offre il nous offre un fusil contre
notre jeu de cartes
un jeu de dames contre 3 cases on prend
le fusil quant aux jeux de cartes mec
pas mal ça comme ça pas manger de
souffrances tues mais on peut peut-être
pu t ta jambe en tirant plein de mag en
dedans cette fausse idée de merde
aujourd'hui un petit bonhomme dont les
arts aux devises et s'est présenté comme
un commerçant d'accord pareil il offre
un cadenas compte le masque à gaz
tu fais quoi canada quand c'est
l'apocalypse mon gars tu vas à la salle
tu peux faire mais le casier dans lequel
ta vie tes affaires waouh aller aux
quais attenant à la salle doit pousser
un peu on va pas se mentir jour 27 ya
plus d'eau monga non mais là faut que
l'on va pas y rentrer un vous l'entendez
à quelque chose sous le plancher
il fait la chaîne et la lampe torche
mais mais elle est partout elle joue 28
du mois que tu as des rentrées s'te
plaît aux jeux transformant son remake
de l'oise a perdu les pédales non je
donne un truc quelqu'un frappe à la
porte mais qu'on doit faire on n'a
trouvé qu'une valise abandonnée sur le
sol
faut-il voir ce qu'il ya dedans oui bay
county pillage ray la valise coin c'est
l'apocalypse le mec a pas que ça à
[ __ ] timmy veulent l'eau dolores veut
1re partie migé pas d'eau mais je suis
désolé ça fait un mois qu'il n'ya pas
intimidés dans un état lamentable nous
devons lui donner de l'eau maintenant
comme on dit en espagne adios amigos
quoi j'ai débuté un cafard radioactifs
jean 32 l'attention avec la petite
amaro fils bonne chance à la pression
d'eau potable poussée à ses limites
civil avait plus de choix innover
rapport de la bri les parties se jeta un
regard vers l'arrière dolores vont avec
infuse et loire d'un [ __ ] de truc de
l'eau reste ma chance à ma chance et
malchance fin nani d'accord donc elle
est sortie la brière s'est tiré une
balle à douala été capturé mais elle
avait refusé et lui arriver quoi elle a
été capturé finalement ça finit bien
tel a été capturé de l'aurès été
capturés sont peut-être en train de
faire des bébés dans un autre abri
c'est fort mais mal je suis sur 60
secondes c'est super sympa vraiment que
je pense que tout le monde a une
histoire différente ça en plus je te
sors plus ou moins selon ce que tu as
réussi à mettre d'autres l'abri dès le
début et on peut dire que nous n'a
vraiment mis que dalle dit penser
portier grec qui a résisté dix jours
sans boire chevaux brut japonais on s'en
bat les couilles à la déesse des
prochaines vidéos partout on vient
justement bis